So if you're thinking about joining an
accelerator, one of the downsides could
be the amount of equity that you
have to give up in return for
the money that you're getting.
Most accelerators will take a fairly
significant piece of equity
in return for all of the mentorship and
the guidance that they provide.
And what you have to ask yourself is,
do you already have that network that's
going to provide you all that feedback?
Or are you interested in
having the accelerator do it?
Because there is a cost
associated with it.
Otherwise, when you look
at an accelerator and
you evaluate it, you really need to
evaluate the accelerator based on that
group of people that's going to help
you, and whether you think that they're
going to help you solve the specific
problem you're trying to solve.